here to present the awards for
scientific and technical achievement his
academy award-winning actress and baxter
the scientific and technical awards are
divided into three classes this year
there are two class one Awards the first
of these is for the introduction of
Eastman color negative and Eastman color
print films mr. Emory Hughes will accept
the Oscar awarded to the Eastman Kodak
Company
thank you very much
and after is awarded for the
introduction of Antico color- a
Nanticoke color print film mr. Robert
Young will except for the Anzio division
general AnnaLynne and filled in
corporations
thank you everyone the class to award is
for an improved method of color motion
picture photography under incandescent
lights the plaque will be accepted by
dr. Herbert Kalmus for the Technicolor
motion picture corporation
members of the Academy Board of
Governors ladies and gentlemen I'm very
proud to accept this great honor or on
behalf of the Technicolor company but
more particularly for the technical
staff of the Technicolor company which
staff for some 30 odd years have been
endeavoring in some small way to help
this great industry to meet every
challenge and I'm sure the industry will
continue to meet those challenges class
three awards in the form of honorable
mention were voted to the following for
the projection research and still
departments of metro-goldwyn-mayer for
an improved method of projecting
photographic backgrounds to John G frame
and our our scovilles and the westrex
corporation for a method of measuring
distortion in sound reproduction to the
photo Research Corporation for creating
the spectra color temperature meter the
Gustave yarosh for the design of the
robot automatic films by Sir - Carlos
Rivas of metro-goldwyn-mayer for the
development of a sound reproducer for
magnetic film on this 25th anniversary
the academy wishes to state publicly its
debt to the vast corps of scientists and
technicians who have brought so much to
the picture industry through the years
and who even now are assaulting new
visual and sonic frontiers of knowledge
for the entire Khadem ii thank you
gentlemen
I told you earlier that the Academy had
once voted a miniature Oscar to Bob Hope
it was given for a variety of reasons
since then so many other reasons have
piled up is an enormous contribution to
the laughter of the world his service to
this industry is devotion to the
American premise that the Academy had to
do something last night we had two
choices we can either give him the
corner of Hollywood and Vine
or we could vote him a richly merited
Oscar
we have practical people I wonder if Bob
Hope would come out here and help me
clear up this
I know there's a joke you take it back
after a while
Thank You Charles I can't well this does
it to me wait I'll go back and check
with my writers I'll be right I can't I
don't know what to say about this I I
just want to tell you that I'm
flabbergasted and this is just just a
what about it man I just want to tell
you that this is wonderful
ah this is really what I dreamed of when
I get off the bus in front of the
Knickerbocker Hotel 15 years ago 15
years now I know how the Republicans
felt when I got there I thought Charles
I just want to thank the Board of
Governors the Academy this is just I
don't I don't believe this
I'm just very appreciative and believe
me and sincerely I will try to live up
to what this means in the future
now to light up that 26th candle the one
to grow up that's for the Irving
Thalberg award it's an honor not given
each year when given it goes to a man
with an extraordinarily high record for
motion picture production to present it
tonight
the first Thalberg Award winner and the
only man who is won it three times mr.
Darryl zanuck
thank you very much it's a great honor
and a great distinction tonight
present the Irving Thalberg award to a
man who certainly needs no introduction
when I came to this business 25 or 26
years ago he was a great name he's kept
pace and he's forged ahead the winner
tonight of the Irving Thalberg award see
B DeMille
now let's say it's a triple honor to
receive the Irving Thalberg award from a
man who has received it three times we
both knew and admired and loved living
Fahlberg for the many great things that
he did for this art the award as I
understand it is far worked on the past
three years and that includes two dreams
that I was able to realize in the past
three years
Samson and Delilah I'm the greatest show
on earth
Samson that that showed the that man's
strength comes from above I'm the
greatest show on earth which is a happy
picture made to make people thrill and
enjoy and millions of kids all over the
world who hadn't even seen circuses
respond Lincoln said to Barnum laughter
is the best medicine now understand that
there are almost 50 million people
listening who are attending this
ceremony tonight through television and
radio I I want to thank them for the way
they receive the motion picture industry
as an art the way they have stood by us
and loved us when we do good work they
respond when we do poor worked they
chastise us by their absence I want to
thank them personally for their
reception particularly I'm going to be
selfish
of these two pictures these two dreams
that were brought to life by so many
people in this industry by by sharing
those dreams they have they have brought
me this award which I shall keep close
to me all of my life I'm very grateful
god bless you
thank you well the candles now we really
let the candles all the candles and the
parties I'm not flustered I've been
alright parties practically over for
this year let's say goodnight to New
York thank you for hub laughter getting
caught short on that last shot I played
safe this time I have a little support
for the people here in New York where
Kim hunter or Freddie March for myself
it's been a great evening because our
Shirley booth won the award thank you
all in Hollywood and good night
I can't tell you how what a great night
it's been for me ladies and gentlemen
this turn into my night CV might have
one too but this is for to me there's a
great thing and I don't is this the same
size as Crosby's that's all I wonder if
he's still up I got to run over there
and check with him okay I don't think I
know that we're all indebted to RCA for
this wonderful help tonight and we're
also indebted to Johnny green for a
wonderful job of production and
Direction here
I think the people of the country just
take a look at you Jeff John I know the
work you've done you've lost about 20
pounds in the last couple of weeks let
me tell you don't put it back on you
look great
yes I just want to take this opportunity
to say a very special word of thanks to
Bob Welch bill Bennington bill Cayton
and Dick clemmer in New York all of the
NBC production staff for this fabulous
television job you've seen tonight thank
you
I think that's very wonderful when they
give credit like that but I don't feel
that way all that I am or whatever I
hope to be I owe to my dramatic coach
Willie Sutton let's give a big hand to a
wonderful guy and one of our great
actors who has been doing the color on
this show tonight Ronald Regan right
here
thank you and of course Paul Douglas is
handling it by air and did a great job I
understand that's the end of twenty five
years ladies and gentlemen we'll have to
break it up now all these people have to
get out of the theater and start on the
next 25 good night